how much do I love the Siddhartha
brothers as much as I love the slap the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of them those two
pretty [ __ ] now I don't know why I do
the stupid [ __ ] that I do it's just a
part of my personality as you guys I
know we have family tradition which is
the traditional a slap now better than
expected I'm pretty sure Peters gonna
expect me to slap his ass but is he
going to expect the 230-pound man in a
ninja suit to smack him the ass with
some nunchucks I guarantee he doesn't
people don't know ninjutsu is a very
difficult
you'll have to focus everything eat
hamburger every day wake up
mispronounced [ __ ] all the path give me
a hammer listen I can't help myself
I have been slapping the crap out of
these two since the first time I ever
met him it's family tradition now I have
to do it I know people say like oh it
looks like it hurts you shouldn't do
that maybe they don't like it
they're not your friends their minds
[ __ ] just gonna do it shits about to get
real sorry Peter I have to do it it's
just it's weird because you get so
accustomed to doing things is it smart
probably not did you show how immature I
am yes am I still gonna do it [ __ ] you
so we scheduled a living out loud with
them and for some reason in my sick
twisted mind I thought to myself why
don't I just go on Amazon Prime right
now by a ninja suit preps a crossbow
perhaps a nunchuck maybe even a plastic
sword and then jump then I realized how
immature I was yesterday when I ordered
this on Amazon as fast as possible just
like a game shoot and I'm pretty sure
whoever looks at my Amazon Lister like
what the [ __ ] is full buying he's buying
a mixer of blenders and kitchen knives
and there's some nerf guns and fake
nunchucks and an adult ninja costume
when it's not even Halloween whoo ninja
you know what other kid I said loved
nerf guns but I was too broke to get the
cool ones but now that I'm old enough I
can get where the [ __ ] I want roundhouse
I have a trainee nerd smart art of
ninjitsu for about 87 year you don't
know but I'm a hundred in the 50 year or
Oh
smoke bomb disappear so basically here's
the plan
in order for me to ambush them I
actually had to have somebody set it up
so I had Vince go down tell them that
we're gonna do it interview outside of
my house and lo and behold and
unbeknownst to them I hid in a dumpster
for a good 15 minutes until they came up
close the darcel brothers what do you
think about David all right thank you
that stupid hate is good sometimes
so the dumpster smelled like hot ass and
rancid [ __ ] juice uh was it worth it
yes
yeah I wasn't there for about 15 minutes
or so and you know that whole time I was
in that dumpster just smelling in that
ass fume I was like it's gonna be worth
it you're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
them with a pair of nunchucks you bought
yesterday did you guys make it out yes
start making out okay so how do you guys
know David how are we not David Jesus
been so long now four or five years oh
no I think we saw him on the corner of
one Street and near is offering only
five dollars per [ __ ] so we took him
up for it yeah but we gave it a little
bit action for tip never lose oh so I
come out of the dumpster right and I'm
sneaky as [ __ ] I'm not wearing any shoes
by the way so they can't hear me I try
to get Peter and I swing at his dumb ass
but I think he's been jumped a lot when
he was a kid because he has that like
spider bully scent he jumps out the way
instead I hit Yoshi in the ribs with the
nunchucks absolutely hilarious
completely worth it myself
still a
Peter being the quick little nimble
Asian man that he hears he dodges my
[ __ ] and he runs away at super like
speed and he was running so fast that
his cute little motor sandals flipped
off of his toes and [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
hurt look like a trip shouting me out my
walking aah hey just as a point and you
know I can't let this go let's talk
about Peter sandals for a second where
the [ __ ] you buy those things huh the
Bible store [ __ ] but like you bought
that [ __ ] from a page in the Old
Testament I kind of crap from reading
and also my feet are from running us a
bit but it was worth it I'm not gonna
lie did you scare the living [ __ ]
I like talkin and silly I look another
my eyes lookin ninja shampoo you know if
you ask me am I going to continue this
family tradition of course I have what
you're what and I next time we do this
it's gonna be a lot crazier I'm gonna
slap him so hard his hair's gonna pop
off the top of his head and attach to
his own [ __ ] he's going to look like
he has an [ __ ] made of a fox tail
what does that mean
you know what's gonna happen right I
don't think it's gonna happen the way
you think man
yeah man you gotta stop slapping our
houses you pretty little lookbook [ __ ]
you can't stop it
trust me I'm gonna get that ass
it's just pull serious don't matter we
can outrun your shamless yeah do the
same come to a Penta for ah yo what the
[ __ ] he just brings a fat hour dude yo
show sir we better get out of here dude
oh my god oh my god with the [ __ ]
food